qu'est ce que vous pensez chacun de la
carrière de l'autre n'a tourné ensemble
déjà harry potter notamment les trois
premiers dans la guerre des étoiles ont
fait des soldats de la force mais
forcément comme on a le masque
chaque fois qu'il ya deux soldats de la
force en blanc
un recteur qui est de la guitare avec
son sexe et ce même acteur qui a joué de
la guitare avec son sexe qui apportait
son césar très haut à la soirée les gens
l'aiment le voir sur scène et les gens
là me voir au cinéma
donc c'est d'une belle réussite bravo
moulin on a eu une ou plusieurs super
idée de scénario à lui proposer comment
avez vous réagi à la lecture du scénario
mais moi j'ai pas lu beaucoup de
scénarios que j'ai pas lu enfin bon
c'est ça ma carrière le proof de toute
façon je suis rendu compte que j'avais
pas lu le bon sert ayew
donc je vais pas lui non plus c'est un
personnage qui kibaki qui avance qui
avance vers la mort moi c'est un
personnage assez complexe sa passion
pour les étiquettes de camembert du
monde entier parce que c'est quand même
une de ses passions qui détermine tout
le personnage
un jour c'est un personnage très ambigu
à me tenterait ambidextre d'une certaine
façon et aux mobylettes et en mobylette
c'est très très heureux de lire le sait
même pas ce que j'écris beaucoup de
choses qui m'ont très ému au sénat lui
d'une traite chez faire mon truc j'ai
fait on fait ça en échange du tout si
vous deviez échanger vos vies qu'est-ce
que vous prendriez chez l'autre sa femme
ses cheveux d'autres sont passés avant
moi non je prendrais son corps tout
entier ça on l'appelle babar dans le
métier vous savez on a quand même une
scène où on est on est tout nu dans le
film donc moi je suis face à lui donc je
les ai vus je prendrais tout son corps
et notamment cette partie là parce que
ça c'est de prendre s à sa coolitude
cigare c'est donc c'était pour lui
rassure les autres moi je prendrais chez
franck sa cave à vin pourquoi parce que
franck ne boit pas de vin et sait même
pas qui la déboutait extrêmement rare et
extrêmement bonnes donc j'ai pu prendre
et sa caméra
est-ce que vous pouvez nous raconter sur
cette fameuse scène de la cave où vous
êtes tenus je ne sais pas nous voilà
c'est on a été doublée par des gens que
vous connaissez très bien
francis lalanne et qui m'a doublé moi
moi c'est monica bellucci et j'avais
comme ça une sélection de corps monsieur
cadet jean dujardin il ya des homards
marina foïs terrible comme ça parce
qu'on est venu donner un poil devant 40
personnes dans du sable
moi j'ai vu en salle j'ai entendu des
gens rient en salle
à ce moment là nous échouons chat très
sympathique de la part du prix c'est pas
très sympathique
[ __ ] je me suis fait flasher merde que
vous avez aimé jouer avec alexandra lamy
alexandre un ami à prouver au monde
qu'elle joue avec elle on n'a jamais vu
quelqu'un se comportait comme ça l'image
que le public adèle absolument fausses
c'est d'abord sa dame
oui alexandre aulas nous le bon tempo et
sera alexandre le monde ça ça sent
vraiment en fait
elle rit beaucoup elle est fan de nos
conneries pts et puis elle est là elle a
une énergie du site une très jolie femme
ce qui ne gâche rien
finalement c'est déjà terminé
on est vraiment dans la merde là